bitcoin is crashing and everyone is
wondering what the hell is going on
let's take a look at the data and
everyone calm down first bitcoin is down
about 12
over the last 24 hours of course that
has people concerned but everything is
down stocks are down and various other
assets as well gold silver euro yen
running b oil everything is down of
course everyone is also scared that the
fed's interest rate decisions are going
to force asset prices lower and so
naturally just as people go and start
buying inflation hedge assets when they
think inflation is on the horizon same
thing here is people sell assets when
they think that the fed is going to make
future interest rate decisions so all
assets are down materially if we go
ahead and we look at bitcoin
specifically it is still above a 700
billion dollar market cap the inflation
rate is unchanged 1.77
bitcoin's monetary policy does not care
what is going on in the world doesn't
care about global pandemics it doesn't
care about the federal reserve and it
sure as hell doesn't care who's buying
and selling it over 90 of it's been
issued but still it is being used at an
incredible pace over 12 billion dollars
of settlement on chain in the last 24
hours bitcoin miners were paid 35
million dollars over the last 24 hours
as well to continue to secure the
network even though bitcoin's price has
gone down the bitcoin miners are still
securing the most secure most powerful
computer network in the world they don't
care either then if we continue when we
look over the last one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten years
guess what it's all up baby minus gold
gold's been down one percent over the
last year my favorite part of this
statistic is that if you bought bitcoin
last year and just held it now for 12
months you're up 20 percent if you
bought gold a decade ago literally your
bitcoin purchased from a year ago
doubled your gold performance from 10
years ago and so ultimately that ends up
being incredible also true is that if
you bought bitcoin two years ago and
held it to today you outperformed the s
p 500 over the last decade
that is what asymmetry does so then if
we go and we look at bitcoin in the
price closing history what we see is
that for 290 days ever in the history of
this asset it has been higher than it is
today about six percent of the time
which means 94
of all days since bitcoin has been
created
it has never been higher than today
which is important to pay attention to
you're not going to make a different
investment decision because of that but
you are going to understand what's going
on then if we go ahead and we look at
bitcoin gold s p 500 nasdaq ntlt
part of my favorite thing here is
bitcoin outperformed all of them over
the last year also those assets are
absolutely poop in the bed when it comes
to the compound annual growth rate over
the last decade bitcoin even though the
price is down has still compounded
annually for a decade at
140 percent it is absolutely bonkers the
sharpe ratio over the last five years
absolutely destroying the other assets
as well but even though the price is
volatile even though bitcoin has gone up
it's gone down it's gone up it's gone
down last year bitcoin had more than six
different times where it dropped 20 or
more it had three times where it dropped
30 or more and it also went down more
than 50 percent one time it also went
down more than 50
in 2018 in 2020 in 2021 none of this
stuff is new everyone calmed the hell
down now why is that important because
guess what the plebs the bitcoiners
they're still stacking sats they don't
care we just hit a brand new all-time
high for bitcoin addresses with a
bitcoin balance of at least 0.01 bitcoin
even though the price is super volatile
bitcoiners keep stacking sats you know
why it's because wall street has tried
to financialize this asset and so when
we went from 10 000
to sixty four thousand dollars at the
end of 2020 to the uh beginning of 2021
from 10 00 to 64 000
the bitcoiners were selling their
bitcoin to wall street wall street was
gobbling it up
now
as we've gone from 69 000 down to 38
wall street's panic selling they're
panic selling and they're selling their
bitcoin back to the bitcoiners and so
bitcoiners stay winning while wall
street keeps buying the bags at the top
and selling them on the way down because
they my friends are short-term thinkers
also the bitcoin miners they don't care
about this either bitcoin's hash rate
continues to hit all-time highs
countries try to take them out nobody
cares the price goes down nobody cares
bitcoin mining continues to hit all-time
highs and also the number of bitcoin
addresses on chain with a .01 bitcoin
balance or higher all-time high
bitcoiners do not care because the
underlying fundamentals are stronger
than they've ever been what do you guys
think about all this
it's a bunch of nonsense everyone's
complaining
just chill zoom out don't worry that's
my that's my advice in january of 2021
on the way up at 38 000 everyone was
freaking out they're like whoa to the
moon
now we hit 38 000 i was like it's gonna
end life is over it's all over
it's 38 000 both ways
don't get too excited and don't get too
down
and if you can just keep control of your
emotions by the way who knows maybe it
goes lower maybe it goes higher i don't
know but if bitcoin goes to a dollar i'm
buying it all
so like if you think about it in the
sense of if it goes down bitcoin's
thesis is still intact if it goes up
bitcoin's thesis is still intact and i
think what people are going to get a
crash course here in is taking timeless
investing principles like
buy a great asset and hold it forever
warren buffett charlie munger all the
value investing all that timeless
investing principles ultimately price
ends up being able to get people over
excited or
get them over fearful but if you just
look at the underlying fundamentals i'm
not selling my bitcoin and i'm buying
more